[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau tour d'horizon
de l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
22 février
elle était la première adjointe de
bernard de bain elle est la première
femme à devenir maire de la ville sonia
bros a été élu jeudi soir à la tête de
saint cyr l'école elle est l'invitée de
cette édition du changement également à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dj fischer nouveau maire de
coignières devient vice président des
affaires sociales et un nouvel élu en
charge de l'économie actes antisémites
mobilisation des enseignants ou encore
début du salon de l'agriculture comme
chaque vendredi coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine
censure à l'école a un nouveau maire
sonia bros bonjour vous avez été élu à
la tête de la commune lors d'un conseil
municipal extraordinaire hier soir une
séance organisée suite à la démission de
bernard de bain à presque un an du
scrutin des municipales
le reportage sur votre élection de
grégory canal est gros et aux planètes
élu maire de la commune de sensible
comme elle est la première femme à
occuper la fonction de maire dans
l'histoire de saint cyr l'école sonia
bros 44 ans a été élu avec 23 des 25
voix de la majorité au conseil municipal
de bulletins blancs exprimer l'ancienne
première adjointe succède à bernard de
bain resté treize ans à la tête de la
commune
c'est un grand honneur c'est beaucoup de
travail j'en suis totalement consciente
mais surtout c'est
cheminement qui a pris 10 ans et je
remercierai jamais assez monsieur de
bain de m'avoir ouvert les portes et de
m'avoir appris le métier de d'élus de
conseillère municipale puis ensuite
d'adjointe est aujourd'hui des mers
séance extraordinaire organisée après la
démission de bernard de bain 72 ans il a
décidé de rendre son écharpe obtenu en
2006 plusieurs raisons avancées
notamment celle de vouloir profiter de
sa famille l'ex maire reste tout de même
au conseil municipal comme troisième
adjoint on a presque un peu l'impression
qu'à la fin avant tout des cas dans les
derniers mois vous expédier les affaires
courantes et je trouve qu'il était
beaucoup mieux que la personne qui va
pouvoir se représenter devant la
population de la ville ça soit celle
qu'ils soient déjà aux commandes
une élection à laquelle n'a pas pris par
l'ensemble des élus des deux groupes
d'opposition de gauche a presque un an
du scrutin des municipales il dénonce
une opération électoraliste orchestrée
par la majorité le maire ne part porte
le seul poste qu'il a cédé et le poste
de
mr qu'il a cédé à sa première adjointe
qui sera candidate aux élections
municipales
c'est vraiment une manoeuvre précipiter
dans une lutte sans merci entre les
éléments différents de la droite ça sert
yens référence au possible retour en
politique de l'ancien maire de droite
philippe lavaud démissionnaire en 2006
qui pourrait faire face à sonia bros aux
élections municipales en 2020
hier soir élection historique à saint
cyr lors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire sonia bros vous avez été
élu vous êtes la première femme de
l'histoire de la ville de saint cyr a
occupé ce poste de maire c'est une
fierté pour vous quel est votre ressenti
alors c'est toujours une fierté quand
une femme donc pour la première fois un
poste
toutefois ce serait une vraie fierté
quand on arrêtera de le signaler
alors certains parlent de manoeuvre
électoraliste et vont même plus loin on
parle d'un possible retour de philippe
lavaud l'ancien maire démissionnaire en
2006 c'est le cas alors en effet il est
à nouveau présent sur le territoire
ça avait été le cas en 2007 ça avait été
le cas aussi en 2013 non démocratie lit
donc chacun viendra se présenter devant
les électeurs avant de prendre le poste
de maire vous étiez la première adjointe
de bernard de bain délégué à la
communication à l'assainissement et aux
ressources humaines
je vous propose d'écouter le bilan que
dresse bernard de bain de son mandat
c'est beaucoup de projets il y en a
qu'on a attendu très longtemps qu'on
voit venir comme le tram 13 il ya eu
énormément de travail sur la casa muda
énormément de travail mais c'est aussi
faire vivre la vie tous les jours
saint cyr n'est pas une ville riche et
sa demande de faire des choix et
j'espère que j'ai fait des bons choix
après toutes ces années passées aux
côtés de bernard de ben quel est votre
bilan
il est riche parce que la ville a
beaucoup évolué ces dix dernières années
on a une ville
et qui avait un nombre d'habitants qui
étaient en baisse et puis petit à petit
qui est remonté c'est un peu le cas de
toutes les villes sont des villes qui
vieillissent et puis qu'ils repartent un
petit peu à la hausse avec cette
nouvelle population sont arrivés de
nouvelles constructions
une nouvelle image de la ville en tous
les cas de modernité de de propreté
aussi parce que parce que c'est plus les
mêmes bâtiments ses pulls mêmes matières
et la ville a vraiment beaucoup évolué
et je pense que vraiment l'image que
j'en garde c'est ça c'est cette
évolution à la fois urbaine à lavau fois
dans le cadre de vie puisque la
naissance du parc de l'abbaye la
naissance du nouveau quartier d'ascq
renard avec beaucoup d'endroits paysage
est donc juste équilibre entre la nature
et et la pierre alors je le rappelle
bernard de bain a démissionné le 14
février en montrant un certain
ras-le-bol et notamment de devoir gérer
la ville en ayant perdu six cent mille
euros de dotations sur un an alors que
saint cyr enregistre 2500 habitants de
plus depuis 2014 et qu'il faut
construire des écoles et des gymnases
des crèches
quel sera votre ligne conductrice pour
diriger la ville notamment sur ces
problématiques
moi j'ai la chance d'arriver à un moment
où justement les grands équipements sont
lancés sont en phase de voir le jour et
pour certains
vraiment bien entamée et aujourd'hui le
vrai défi maintenant c'est de d'arriver
à faire vivre toute cette nouvelle
population en harmonie et donc on est
vraiment plus sur un projet humain de
vie dans notre ville alors justement sur
ces problématiques il a été reproché
plusieurs choses à bernard de bain je
vous propose d'écouter cet extrait ce
qu'il faut retenir les grands éléments
je pense qu'ils ont vraiment marqué la
commune ce sont les impôts les impôts
c'est une hausse de 38 % la taxe
d'habitation à sociales l'école tout
simplement on a battu le record de
france de la taxe d'habitation
là haut je taxe d'habitation c'est à
saint cyr qu'elle augmentait le plus de
toutes les communes de france
que lui répondez-vous à sébastien durand
que c'est toujours facile de critiquer
quand on est dans l'opposition que
évidemment oui enfin je rappelle quand
même que c'était ses amis qui était à
l'époque au gouvernement et qui ont en
cinq ans baissé les dotations de façon
drastique
deux ans avant on était
remarqué par challenge comme étant la
ville la mieux gérée avec des taux
d'impôts très bas et c'était le cas sauf
qu'à un moment donné en effet une fois
que les dotations les recettes fondent
il faut quand même continuer à rendre le
service aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
imaginer une ville où il n'y a pas de
cantine dans l'école et une cantine dans
l'école même si vous vendez un repas 4
euros 60
cela reste un coût du repas à 8 euros
etc des frais de fonctionnement qui sont
énormes
pourquoi on augmente les impôts on a
aussi fait le choix de pas uniquement
d'augmenter les impôts s'il avait fallu
augmenter les impôts en proportion de ce
qu'on a perdu c'était plus de 50%
on a aussi fait le choix de de faire de
grosses économies et de vraiment
travailler sur la gestion jeu j'entends
bien c'est pas agréable l'augmentation
d'impôt jeux j'habite saint siège les
prix aussi et quels sont vos projets
pour la ville de saint cyr l'école comme
je disais tout à l'heure
saint cyr est une ville qui a beaucoup
évolué au niveau urbanistique ces
dernières années et là vraiment l'enjeu
pour moi c'est d'arriver à faire se
rencontrer tous et saint cyrien à leur
faire aimer leur ville à ce qu'ils
puissent se l'approprier
ce part bien entendu le cadre de vie
mais aussi par les services qui leur
sont proposés par une modernisation de
nos services de façon assez importante
alors vous étiez je le rappelle la
première adjointe de bernard de bain sa
démission vous ouvre donc les portes
pour les municipales de 2001 vous y
pensez oui bien sûr donc lorsque nous
avons fait la campagne en 2014
bernard demain avait annoncé qu'il ne se
représenterait pas en 2020 et déjà à
l'époque j'avais expliqué que si le
mandat se passait bien si je prenais ma
place en tant que première adjointe
je serai candidate en 2020 ce qui a été
le cas hier soir les élus de saint
quentin en yvelines ont tenu une séance
au siège de la communauté
d'agglomération attrape un conseil
communautaire pour notamment renouveler
trois vice-présidences bernard des bancs
a été élu vice président aux sports
suite à la demie
il y a près d'un an de jean pierre se
baissent depuis ce poste était resté
vacant
othman natrue hérite du développement
économique une compétence qu'il connaît
suite à ces différentes expériences
écoutez le j'avais déjà pris une
responsabilité avec la pépinière
d'entreprises propofol qu'il fallait
redresser notamment réussi à redresser
sans que cela coûte un euro au
contribuable
je me suis occupé de la commission du
développement économique de
l'agglomération de saint quentin est
donc aujourd'hui effectivement cette
vice-présidence au développement
économique c'est l'occasion pour moi de
continuer et bien l'action en faveur de
l'emploi du développement économique du
territoire
une quinzième vice-présidence a été créé
dans le domaine de l'action sociale et
le nouveau maire de coignières didier
fischer a été désigné pour occuper cette
fonction
réaction je remercie bien le président
de me faire confiance pour cette
quinzième vice présidence on voit que la
représentation coignières au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération a quelque peu
diminué quand même hein on avait une
vice-présidence on avait aussi un
conseiller en fait conseillère déléguée
on voit aujourd'hui on a plus qu une
vice-présidence ensuite au sein d'un
certain nombre d'organismes n'y figure
plus au sein d'un certain nombre de
commissions n'y figure plus donc il ya
quand même il ya quand même une
une inquiétude par rapport à cela alors
je comprends bien les logiques
politiques un la majorité et la minorité
mais d'une certaine manière mais
habitant mérite quand même mieux
aujourd'hui sincère à l'école fait
partie de l'agglomération versailles
grand parent pouvons nous imaginer que
la commune intègre un jour saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est de toute façon des choses qui sont
qui sont toujours étudiées sans vouloir
réellement aller d'un côté ou de l'autre
on fait partie des communes fondatrices
de versailles grand parc
on y est attaché pour autant on a une
population à saint cyr l'école qui est
quand même beaucoup plus proches de
celles de 50 a donc on regarde toujours
ce qui se passe à saint quentin où est
donc une collaboration avec cette
collectivité c'est possible ou c'est du
complètement écarté une collaboration
c'est toujours possible
vous avez vu que ce trophée le 78 92 il
ya plein de choses qui sont possibles
tout de suite on passe au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
les actes antisémites ont augmenté de
74% en france l'an passé des actes en
recrudescence cette semaine sa cage des
arbres plantés à la mémoire d'ilan
halimi à sainte geneviève des bois en
essonne croix gammée sur des
représentations de simone veil plusieurs
marches ont été menées la ville de
poissy organisé une cérémonie
rassemblant des représentants des cultes
de la ville sur notre plateau nous avons
reçu le rabbin saint quentinois à mende
l ennemi c n'gbo il ya un sentiment je
vais je veux dire d'inquiétude
un sentiment d'inquiétude parce que
l'histoire du peuple juif en france est
très ancienne depuis le moyen âge
il ya le grand auteur rachis qui vivait
à troyes en champagne qui était un
vignoble donc l'histoire du peuple juif
en france est très ancien et toujours en
a toujours eu des juifs en france et la
france fait partie aussi de notre
histoire de notre vie nous avons
toujours vécu en france c'est la raison
pour laquelle s'il ya eu aujourd'hui
cette inquiétude qui est de ce vivre
ensemble qui est aujourd'hui remis en
question sonia bros en tant que maire
une petite réaction c'est l'une de vos
priorités de vous opposer à toute forme
de racisme je vois c'est la priorité de
tout citoyen est encore plus lorsqu'on
est élu et dans un territoire
autre mobilisation marquant de cette
semaine la mobilisation des enseignants
ils étaient nombreux à se réunir devant
plusieurs établissements du département
cette semaine par exemple devant le
collège l'agio à elancourt ou aussi
devant le collège philippe champagne du
mesnil saint denis
ils dénoncent la diminution du nombre
d'heures attribuées par établissement et
des conséquences engendrées plus de
précision avec ce reportage
ils veulent se faire entendre professeur
représentant parents et élus protestent
contre la dotation horaire des
établissements attribué à la rentrée
prochaine
nous sommes tous aujourd'hui devant ce
collège philippe de champaigne puisque
nous avons reçu il ya une semaine voire
dix jours la dotation horaire globale
pour la mise en place de la rentrée 2010
9 et il se trouve qu'elle n'est pas du
tout en adéquation avec des effectifs
prévue l'année prochaine pour la rentrée
de septembre il est prévu des classes de
30 élèves du jamais vu pour ce collège
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 24 25
élèves par classe et on a un collège
atypique qui est sur deux communes qui
ont deux profils différents sur le
ministre a nié la verrière avec des
parcours scolaires différents et être à
30 par classe pour eux c'est c'est pas
possible pour alerter sur ses futures
conditions ils arrêtaient les
automobilistes en plus des classes
surchargées les accompagnements
éducatifs sont aussi menacés on craint
également la perte des différents
projets des différents dispositifs qui
nous permettent de faire davantage de
différenciation pédagogique notamment
sur des ennemis groupe ou sur des
projets science des projets autour du
français des projets interdisciplinaires
que l'on risque de perdre pour l'an
prochain est dédiée hier soir c'est au
collège de la shoah il encourt que
parents et professeurs se rassembler
soucieux également de la qualité de
l'enseignement dispensé aux enfants on
va essayer aussi de de sensibiliser
davantage les parents qu'ils se rendent
compte que ba 30 élèves par classe ça ne
permet pas une différenciation et ça ne
permet pas d'amener les élèves à la
réussite il faut que les parents aussi
en soit conscient ce sont leurs enfants
moi ma fille en 6e donc
pour le moment je sens pas enfin je vois
pas trop l'intérêt pour elles mais je
sais qu'à moyen terme va être concerné
par les deux suppressions place
j'ai pas forcément envie que que son
enseignement soit dégradée un mouvement
qui continuera dans la tente d'un rendez
vous avec elle la direction académique
des yvelines
sonia bronze est également conseillère
départementale l'éducation une de vos
priorités
oui je pense que nos enfants c'est
vraiment notre priorité
moi j'ai la chance sur mon canton de pas
avoir été trop impacté au niveau des
collèges
je comprends je comprends tout à fait la
mobilisation et des professeurs et des
parents nos enfances les adultes de
demain et on sait déjà les
problématiques que rencontrent la france
en terme d'échec scolaire en tant qu en
termes de manque de formation
je pense qu'en effet le collège c'est
vraiment le moment où il faut mettre les
moyens
merci sonia bourreau nouvelle maire de
saint cyr l'école merci d'avoir été
notre invité à la veille du salon de
l'agriculture direction auffargis la
ferme de la petite coque recevez la
députée aurore bergé pour lui faire part
des difficultés qu'elle rencontre dans
sa volonté de production naturelle et
respectueuse de l'animal et de
l'environnement le reportage de marie
lehn iapichino elles ont la charge noir
et les jours noirs des poules faverolles
des cochons gascon et du rock
la ferme de la petite aux gars auffargis
s'emploie depuis des années à
réintroduire des espèces menacées
dans un souci d'élevage le plus naturel
possible eric sens aux apparats en
exemple dans le bien-être animal jeu
réintroduit toutes ces espèces pour
montrer que avec une nourriture commune
un espace un environnement commun on a
quand même une spécificité génétique et
donc on a un goût différent en fonction
des espèces dernière victoire en date la
naissance de deux petits veaux au rock
une espèce préhistorique détendue et
sereine comme toutes leurs voisines des
tables pas radio classique
donc je peux vous dire c
dans une dynamique d'échangé de
questionnements autour du bien-être
animal
aurore bergé a répondu à l'invitation de
l'éleveur une journée pour aborder un
sujet d'actualité
l'abattage ici tout est fait dans la vie
de l'animal pour qu' ils soient dans les
meilleures conditions possibles en
termes de reproduction et en termes
d'élevage mais à partir du moment où
l'animal est transportée jusqu'à son
abattage
il ya un certain nombre de questions qui
se posent pour vérifier la traçabilité
la manière avec laquelle l'animal va
être considéré et jusqu'à son abattage
la jeune association en faveur de
l'abattage des animaux dans la dignité
afad était présente pour apporter son
expertise
il n'y a aucun abattoirs aujourd'hui en
france qui est vraiment digne de ce
travail de qualité qui a effectué alors
il ya des abattoirs qui travaillent bien
mais aujourd'hui le niveau il est quand
même largement en deçà de ce qui est de
ce qui devrait être trappe de bien être
animal
l'afad réfléchit à des abattoirs mobile
qui permettrait de supprimer le
transport de l'animal lui permettant une
fin de vie digne et sereine et samedi
débute le salon de l'agriculture
organisée à paris à porte de versailles
et parmi les exposants la ferme de
viltain sera la représentante du terroir
des yvelines la ferme de viltain
présente cette année c'est nouveau
yaourt récemment labellisé produit en
ile de france et bleu blanc coeur pour
leur teneur en oméga 3 de nombreux
établissements scolaires et entreprises
du département choisi les yaourts de la
ferme de viltain pour leur restauration
le département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine seront aussi présent avec
un stand commun au salon de
l'agriculture qui débute je vous le
rappelle et samedi lé prix villes et
villages de france fleuries ont été
remis mardi à plaisir en 2018 63 commune
yvelinoise se sont vus décerner entre
une et quatre fleurs un beau palmarès
pour le seul département fleuri d'île de
france
cette année ce label a une saveur
particulière puisqu'il fête ses 60 ans
d'existence depuis 60 ans et petit
panneau jaune qui fleurissent aux
entrées de nos communes sont toujours
autant convoité en 2018 dans les
yvelines 63 communes ont été labellisés
villes et villages fleuris
18 chaque année on en a quelques-unes
supplémentaire et on voit une
participation plus en plus importante
pour ses 60 printemps le label s'est
refait une petite beauté
mais ces objectifs n'ont pas changé il
garantit les démarches d'amélioration du
cadre de vie et renforce les qualités
d'attractivité des communes donc je joue
plus la quantité de fleurs mais nous
avons une grille d'évaluation
transversale qui récompense en fait une
stratégie vertueuse des espaces verts
une volonté politique
le jury composé d'une vingtaine de
membres a parcouru l'été dernier
l'ensemble du département
fontenay-le-fleury par exemple a obtenu
sa troisième fleur dans les yvelines
seules trois villes ont de nouveau
décroché le graal à savoir quatre fleurs
c'est le cas du vésinet une habitude
depuis 1992 tout est possible aussi avec
avec une participation aussi de
l'urbanisme une participation des élus
un sens leur application et
l'implication des services techniques
pour pourraient pas obtenir garder les
quatre fleurs qui sont quand même une
valorisation de qualité de vie un label
qui encourage le renforcement de la
nature en ville pour découvrir les
bonnes pratiques déjà mises en place aux
quatre coins du département des visites
sont organisées tout au long de l'année
c'est destiné aux élus des qui sont en
charge de ce sujet développement durable
nature en ville et ses destinée aussi
aux jardiniers des espaces verts des
communes vive les noix les inscriptions
pour le label 2019 ouvriront en avril
prochain du théâtre pour rompre
l'isolément et reprendre confiance en
soi depuis huit ans la ville de
guyancourt propose deux semaines de
stage à des personnes en recherche
d'emploi
une collaboration entre le service
emploi et la ville ainsi que la ferme de
bel ébat marylène ni à pishin au a suivi
ces comédiens d'un jour
donc toi tu dit olivier alors tu prends
ta femme tu prends l'ascenseur ce mardi
matin à guyancourt
on se distribuent les répliques et faut
que amos et une sève à sa disposition
ça va être toi
et les rôles tous sont en recherche
d'emploi ils participent à ce stage pour
une reprise de confiance en soi
en fait moi je suis justement comédien
actuellement j'ai fait j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu sortis du circuit
donc je suis allé voir des services
sociaux du coup leurs yeux sont allumés
quand j'ai dit bon comédien m'a envoyé
ici
le but c'est pas qu'on soit des
professionnels c'est vraiment on prend
tant qu'amateur et en tant que personnes
qui vont juste s'amuser juste montrer un
peu ce qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent valoir
deux semaines de préparation durant
lesquelles ils ont écrit leurs propres
textes et monter une pièce de 15 minutes
le thème était tout trouvé le travail
alors prenez la porte et maintenant ils
sont dirigés par le metteur en scène
françois chaffin en résidence à la ferme
de bel ébat ses douze stagiaires
monteront sur scène en avant première de
sa pièce
c'est une manière aussi de dédramatiser
de prendre un peu de distance par
rapport à un quotidien assez solitaire
de recherche d'emploi le grand jour est
arrivé dernier mouvement du stress en
coulisses moi j'ai peur dépendamment des
trous j'ai peur de pas savoir comment
m'y prendre
j'ai peur que les gens que j'ai peur
avant d'épater les spectateurs sous les
projecteurs mois pour ce stage issue
d'un partenariat entre la ville et la
ferme de bel ébat existe depuis 2012 une
aventure que les élus en charge de
l'emploi et de la culture ne sont pas
prêtes à abandonner garantir le
la prise en compte pour les demandeurs
d'emploi de même aussi bien dans leur
corps que dans leur expression c'est
très important
les artistes qui sont en résidence ici
on cette mission aussi d'aller chercher
les cliniques un vrai groupe qui s'est
formé désormais prêt à affronter cette
recherche d'emploi bien entouré et vous
confiance
tout de suite l'actualité dans le reste
de l'île de france avec nos confrères de
via grand paris
[Musique]
partons à paris dans le 15ème
arrondissement où un nouveau quartier se
construit les travaux sont prêts la fin
des travaux est prévue pour 2026 ce
projet accueillera notamment la plus
grande toiture végétalisée de paris la
première pierre de 400 logements posée
par julien de normandie ministre de la
ville et du logement
un nouveau quartier verra le jour dans
le 15e arrondissement
il sera situé entre les rue lecourbe
desnouettes et croix nivert superficie
2,3 hectares alors qu'ils accueillent le
site de maintenance des métros de la
ligne 12
le lieu va être modernisé la moitié des
logements seront sociaux fait rare le
projet porté par la ratp a fait
consensus auprès des habitants on a été
très respectueux des riverains et c'est
un projet de 2,3 hectares sur lequel on
n'a eu aucun problème d'attac du permis
ou du projet ce qui montre l'ampleur de
la concertation qui a lu autour autour
du projet autour de ces logements des
commerces de bouche et une
halte-garderie vont être créés cerise
sur le gâteau le quartier accueillera la
plus grande toiture végétalisée de paris
elle s'étendra sur quinze mille mètres
carrés au total 700 m² seront consacrés
à l'agriculture urbaine la vision du
projet qui est porté
elle et moi conforme à la vision que je
me fais de la ville de demain
c'est-à-dire un projet qui est inclusif
un projet qui prône la mixité sociale un
projet qui allie à la fois logement mais
aussi mobilité mais aussi emploi puisque
l'on maintient les sites industriels un
projet qui avive construction mais
environnement avec ce 3 végétalisée ses
activités agricoles le projet devrait
définitivement sortir de terre en 2026
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information dans le 7-8 journal
lundi à 18h passer un excellent week-end
[Musique]